hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play curse of the
Aztecs now this is actually a pretty
well made game on the unity engine that
I know nothing about so I'm just gonna
start the game and not skip the tutorial
because I don't know how to play this
starting game
let's see WASD keep the move pretty
simple they're very very low mouse
sensitivity loads will provide details
of what is up it can't be this appears
to be Galloway's writing you and I go
back a long way Marshall yes Marshall I
know we've never seen eye to eye but you
must listen to me
okie dokie we were both wrong Marshall
Marshall this temple redefines oh whoops
wow man it can't damn it okay this
appears to be Galloway's whoa all right
you guys heard it sorry to ruin that
before you let me recreate it Marshall
my goodness Marshall what have you done
Marshall what does that hand doing over
there why is there a hand floating there
oh because there's a there's a button
okay so I just turned on a torch but
apparently I can tell where things are
from a distance other than that I gotta
say this game looks pretty good they
obviously put a lot of work into it
reminds me of labyrinth you know and the
one with the beasts of legend hold shift
to run do I need to run is there a
monster behind me ctrl to crouch once
again pretty basic wait a minute wasn't
Isis here
why wasn't I just here oh this seems
like a pretty simple puzzle if I could
touch any of it geez
all right come on moving along let's go
okay there we go I can't seem to touch
the inner ring why is this why is that
that way I seriously I can't seem to
touch the inner ring oh I got a presses
button okay well that doesn't help at
all
they don't even line up wow whatever
good enough got it nailed it all right
I'm a pro nothing can stop me I'm too
smart for these things whoa
hello skulls as you know he Aztecs were
fond of their dismemberment in
sacrifices what is that oh is that just
a light okay I don't think there's
anything actually over here okay so I
got to solve this stupid puzzle with my
amazing brain since apparently this is
loops back to where it already was so uh
what's the secret here why don't why
does this only move in quarter turns
maybe I just gotta line them all up
maybe that's the thing I gotta do if so
you're being a pain in the buns okay
let's just get this over with
there we go
sweet all right I got a score of 10 I
must be amazing okay this is the same
note right this place oh it's not edible
I find myself in shear or of its
magnificence or I can't just sit here
and wait for the archeological team I'm
standing in the greatest discovery of
ancient history I simply can't remain
idle I'm up I must press on yeah no time
to read ramblings from other people I
must press on so once again triggering
traps can slow you down
like that that's a trap how about kill
me just slow me down or kill me ow what
the hell is that
geez all right then so hello what the
hell what
I'm sorry marshal why why are you sorry
and what is that to help kill get get
get get kill kill kill kill die die die
die no rise no rise Oh
okay all right then help wire Marshall I
have taken a few artifacts and jewels
back to base can some of the treasures
in here are beautiful I could write a
whole book on their incredible cross
museum okay
oh wait was there more what there wasn't
are whatever help me how about I help
myself because this seems kind of bad
hmm what what huh
what's over there what over there huh
why's my Gorge turn blue didn't
something say that what my torch turns
blue I need to run aah
all right okay none of that No thank you
I don't want it
ah crap ah I got
Roberto Oh Ronnie about art oh I'm so
dead I'm sorry dude
why wouldn't you run I don't care about
a history lesson
I wanna not die that's what I want to do
was mighty use the gods he's so
fervently wash okay whatever this is
skip the tutorial I guess get right into
it
ah crap
ah crab how's that good that good is
that good press tab to check your map
okay so there's a monster in here and
apparently I can only sprint for ten
feet and we'll never recuperate ever
never I saw that I saw that
okay now I'm slowed down okay I see a
light over there
where is he though he's in front of me
ah ah right I knew he was in front of me
again why hi hi monster I'm gonna do a
Juke I'm gonna figure out how again I'm
murdering myself with giant oh no I
didn't do Q very good hi okay running
running running around ah I thought he
got me there oh come on
I can't run how am I supposed to win
this seriously my speed of running is
zero absolutely zero please tell me this
isn't the same place I was at before
completing astronomy puzzles to gain
treasure what would I care about
treasure I didn't want to get out of
here coz this place is not fun
what how do I get past these trap how
again y ou get past them okay what's on
the ground over there oh I got coins
more bonus for my treasure score which I
care so much about uh more coins thank
you oh crap yup over it we're sprint
over it apparently
I is someone there
sorry thank you for the treasure I'm
slightly perturbed by this entire
situation but I don't see any others
don't do that to me don't do that to me
don't thinking give me with cheap loud
jump scares I mean you can get me with
cheap loud jump scares but not today
I think this is I remember seeing lights
like this before
haha
where the hell did you come from
mm I'm not gonna be able to do that are
you kidding me there's a giant monster
right behind me oh crap I was just here
it must be something towards these
lights over here because that's where I
saw the other one before they say oh
wait no they're just holes in the
ceiling ah crap crap crap cycle
craptastic
okay I like this magical torch I have
that OOP OOP OOP mMmmm
can let me out let me on the back thank
you yeah I did another one oh wait green
orbs indicated door to the previous
floor ah crap did I just go backwards
way no that's green okay that wasn't
green it looked green
okay so we're doing pretty good and I'm
kind of settling into the game here
hello still some disturbing things but
the month okay thank you very much
yay I got a good score from that I'm
sure that'll be totally worth it when I
can get out of here alive right right
right
hi seriously there's just some
random-ass strange noises going on all
over the place oh crap hey buddy how's
it going friend yeah how you doing
you're looking good man have you been
working out oh man really tell me about
it later table out never tell me about
it never let's go with never dark door
nor dark door let me through whoa I
don't care damn you oh I did the double
finger defense too late but anyway
alright so that was curse of the Aztecs
a pretty good game of you ask me I think
it's randomly generated so anything down
below the levels are gonna be a new
scare
well not really a new scare cuz it's the
same monster but at least it'll be a new
new level so you can't predict where
you're supposed to go right so anyway
try for yourself link it in the
description support the developers it's
totally free I'm not saying buy it but
support the developers anyway so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos it I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
up here
Oh
don't
bud
what is the flash